hi so can you hear me okay if you ever
cannot hear me fine way for something
because I don't speak very loudly
normally so the microphone is good but
if we lose the microphone then just let
me know and just to get a feeling of the
room how many people have a spark in
production here just to make sure okay
so a bunch of guys well yeah right so
you don't need to be convinced about
anything so part of the talk will be
completely unnecessary for you right how
many people here have looked at Scala
just sort of out of curiosity okay right
okay so I'm going to tell you about my
experience looking at Scala and spark so
I'm the director of data science retreat
and we've been teaching machine learning
data engineering for like three years in
mostly mostly with Python and R and
recently in the last year or so we
started using Scala to to teach and to
do delivery projects and so on so I have
done the same tasks twice once in Python
and once in Scala spark and then I can
tell you what what my feelings were when
I do the same thing twice so to start
with kind of obvious introductions so
python a scala language is sort of very
large all-encompassing machine learning
tools libraries actually spark is not
only machine learning it's a whole bunch
of other things and the main thing that
differentiates them is that in this the
left side of the Ring do you have one
machine only so you have to worry about
the memory of one machine the CPU of one
machine and in this part of the world
that the whole game is to be distributed
so that's basically the the main thing
that that this discussion is going to be
about right so for me it's important to
answer a question with this talk so the
question will be like why should I
bother to to go to the side right right
so what is talk well how you go from
single machine to
multiple machines and apparently the
obvious answer now is the spark machine
learning and the lingering question here
could be like am I missing out if I'm
mistaken in the Python world right so I
don't know if I got to be able to answer
that question it's kind of a very
personal thing but I'm going to try to
give you my view of the world right so
you may be thinking well yes part there
is spice Park so why do I bother
so I just stay with past Park right so
one thing that I'm going to cover here
is the dangers of using PI spark so
there are some consequences of not being
on the native platform sort of it's not
horrible but it's not ideal either so
right so take a sorry city so if you
don't know what this it works as it's a
retreat so it's for people who who know
what they are doing but they want to be
much better and then they fly from all
parts of the world like literally like
Brazil Korea Vietnam all kind of weird
places they come for too early for three
months and we hit them very hard with
basically all this data there are things
that we can imagine mostly a streaming
machine learning deep nets are becoming
a big thing all the things that that you
think oh I could learn this by myself
but it would take such a long time so
then you get some badass to to just show
you how he does things and did you get
the best practices and so on I think
that's the way people are attracted to
to this right so the metals are pretty
pretty interesting people in general we
accept very few people but that's just
normal I mean many applications are not
that interesting some of them are
interesting but they are missing one
little bit
which could be deveneux machine learning
so they could be kick-ass bi guys who
know sequel like better than you but
they don't know machine learning and
then you set them back and they study
and they come back to you right so we
really want them to be able to
communicate well with stakeholders and
people who'd understand machine learning
that's
important because I've seen many
projects failed to get support just
because the data scientists don't know
how to explain to the rest of the
company what they are doing and then who
is this guy who is working around
costing us a lot of money and nobody
understands what he's doing so we want
to avoid that so there are technical
communication sessions where you just
improve your your communication skills
basically people who when they come they
have about five years of experience on
average and we we work with a bunch of
companies who want to hire talent and
apparently these companies are very
happy because they keep coming back so I
think that the product that we are
resolving but I may be wrong is that
there is a valley of death so there are
a bunch of people who have certain
amount of skills data science that they
can fit random forests and they can tell
you why a model is better than another
but there is like a huge area here what
there is not much going on and then they
have you have the super good guys who
who could do the next on your
performance and there is nothing between
this is my experience so I think this is
what happens when you come to a super
intensive retreat that you kind of jump
over the value of death or list you try
right so examples of portfolio projects
let me see if I can click on this screen
which I cannot apparently well it's a
video of participant who built a smile
recognition system so to cool the smile
on this this bar will go green and it
could work with multiple faces on
real-time video zone this was like 1/2
years ago now this is actually kind of
common but before it was not that common
so one of the attendants to high-end a
resist his hand he was there to hire and
then he says like why do you want the
job like just put this in production
make a company out of this and don't get
the job like he actually did so anyway
so right here is actually working now on
detecting fake smiles which is kind of
interesting
right in general people are very happy
you can see smiley faces and so on they
keep in touch and they they tell
everybody what they are doing they are
doing crazy stuff for pretty interesting
companies right so why is this are
talking about Scala and spark here so
like plant is actually the company
behind the Scala they used to be called
typesafe but they changed the name kind
of like Google and these guys got
approached by IBM who is running this
Big Data University to create training
materials for data scientists who want
to do things in a Scala and in this part
that they don't know how they know the
typical machine learning topics and so
on but they don't know they how right so
then they approached us to create
training materials for for this that big
data University their videos their I
five to ten minutes and their to the
point so you want to run query push
these three parties how it works is how
you can pair it with other models right
so interestingly in the market
apparently people who are doing a spark
are really interested in doing it
natively in Scala and you will see why
soon there's plenty of Python for sure
Patrice Morris column I don't know what
that means so this is a totally
subjective graph of programming
languages in data science I think our
was super hot up to a certain point it
keeps growing but it's sort of God
taking over I don't even know I don't
have empirical data for this this is
just my gut feeling
basically by talking to data science
badasses and so this could be not over
could be far ahead I have no clue I just
draw in something that's my gut feeling
and what I think is happening is that
Scala is about here it's growing very
fast so the slope is higher than any of
these two and it's mostly about
spark so most people go to
Escarra because they they try this park
and it's such a nice much so I would
like this talk to to give you a
superpower and for me the superpower
will be that if somebody approaches you
to do a project on a spark and this is a
company that is not using any Python and
they cannot do any Python banks or big
companies like that I want you to be
able to say yes or maybe after this talk
this is a very big challenge and you
will see later on how we're going to get
there because with 40 minutes of talking
it's not going to happen but I would
like that to be the superpower that you
get after this talk to be able to say
maybe to a project that is using Scala
and spark
even if assuming that you know psyche
learn Python really well and you can do
machine learning on your own right right
so
Scala has certain advantages apparently
one thing that people keep telling me is
that they seem to refactor code by
nicely because of the type system that
is super sophisticated and complex doing
things for them they don't rely on tests
so much fine I have experienced this but
the main thing to consider is that is
color and the spark are really really
close to each other so if you learn one
you learn the other and this is kind of
a freebie so if you really wanted to get
very far with spark maybe one easy thing
to do is to learn Scala because the
collections library is pretty much the
same in Scala in this park so somebody
thought oh what happens if we do the
same thing that the Scala is doing but
distributed and that's a spark so if you
are really really interested in getting
deep into a spark Escalus is the way
basically because the the same
philosophy the same mindset it's it's
there and you probably know that in
spark there are plenty of our future is
not only a machine learning library and
there is more than one now
their sequel query engines there are
streaming processing things this is
changing very much no and there is graph
processing tooling this was not only
machine learning right so there are
people who think that spark is going to
take over and eventually everybody's
going to be doing a spark right now it
doesn't sound super possible because
it's so exciting to do so much with one
single machine and most public datasets
are not worth putting on a cluster so
it's actually not that easy that to
finally the set that you really need
that cluster to run your your model zone
right but this may be changing very fast
right so one other interesting feature
of this kind of spark world is that
everything is under one roof right so
you have the spark core and then you
have all these things and they are all
the same library so in Python if you
want machine learning you have secondary
you have graphs you have data maybe or
other things you want a streaming well I
actually don't know produces Park and
sequel engines well you have segurança
means things like that so there are
different libraries and they are not
integrated and this thing been one
single core it's useful because you can
go from graphs to two data frames and
the same thing and the people who are
maintaining the projects are built in
the same thing so it's not like oh let's
see if the sequel alchemy guys are
talking to some other group to the
pandas guys maybe not so right and
apparently people who are using this
park in production are very happy and
one of the things they report to be
happy about is this integration so they
use they use more than one of these
blocks right so the the model first part
is of course distributed computing so
how do they do it they have one driver
that sends code running your algorithm
to different workers so the data stays
in the workers and the code moves around
so that was Hadoop's
main innovation sort of so they built on
top of that so the the obvious example
work out you may be sick of seeing work
on the samples by now so one thing that
is important is that data is immutable
in the Python world both tuples are
immutable but it's not that important to
operate with data structures that are
immutable in the functional programming
world people really invested in
immutable data types and by default
everything is immutable in a spark so
that buys you some some performance and
some characteristics that you are going
to to appreciate when you are debugging
it right so in in the MapReduce world
this will be a map where you go from
these two individual worlds and then
this will be another map where you
assign an integer which is account and
then there is one reduce operation where
data is shuffle so you have to move
things around machines and this is
costly you want to avoid that right so
this situation is still in a spark
there's nothing that has been improved
over Hadoop okay now we are going to get
into the interesting part a part if you
are using PI spark so when you run this
is that code for for this same workout
example when you run lambda this is
going to be pipelined into a python
executor and the entire thing is only
executed when you run an action like
saving the zone so everything is lazy
and waiting for you to set the default
in this park is not to do any
competition so let's hope we don't have
to do anything and then when somebody
actually says that well actually bring
me an ADA then you run the entire
pipeline but everything is lazy by
default so this ideas of the in being
lazy and be immutable or strong points
it comes from functional programming
languages nothing new Under the Sun but
doing it in a distributed way and in an
easy way
it's the new thing that this part brings
right and it also brings a fault
tolerance
in a totally different way compared to
Hadoop Hadoop was just replicating
things like factor of two or three in a
spark they round the graph of operations
if you lose a node and some data that
should be there is not then you you go
back in the graph and recompute
everything to create the data so it's
fault tolerant even though you don't
have the replication that that Hadoop
has right so PI spark on our disease so
are this artists res Island distributed
data sets and so on this is the one
place where I've seen the the
architecture explained so when you
generate a spark context you get this pi
4j spawned with a socket and then this
will go to the workers and a star
different Python executors right so the
interesting thing is that would you call
a lambda function to operate on the LDV
each spark worker Forks a Python worker
and data has to move from the JVM to
Python Compaq yes because of the lambda
and this is why performance is not great
and this is why if something dies the
the executor really cannot tell and this
is a little bit of a problem now there
is a solution for that
so remember that I mentioned that there
are some dangers that this is one danger
right so there is some overhead for
cannainsider I see things there is
overhead wrapping objects from one
language to the other but also the class
of manager doesn't know anything about
Python memory requirements and that's
problematic because it's very often the
case that spark chokes on one single
node having either structure that
doesn't fit the memory of the node the
typical example is a group by operation
so you have imagine the Facebook Graph
and you want to group by number of
friends and you have girls and boys and
then one node has like several million
things to count and then chokes and dies
another side effect of this wrapping
from one language to another is that the
error messages are not great sometimes
you get a stack trace in Python
sometimes you have to go down to the JVM
and then good luck to you finding what
maps to weapon to what and so on
excuse me right so what is the solution
to to performance problems the solution
is to never do the are these filtering
with lambdas directly but using data
frames so everybody loves data frames
I'm a very useful concept so do you have
data frames in spark and if you do it
like this it does everything in the JVM
and there is no spamming of all our
process for Python and so on if you want
UDF's like functions that you create and
so on and maps and soon you still need
to serialize but well you can do a lot
with this syntax without having to
resort to to go out and create functions
and you can actually write the functions
in Scala and then map them if you really
want to go that down low-level right so
you may be thinking well but why do I
want a distributed data frame which is
one of the nice things of using this
park well there is some kind of range
where you are perfectly fine with a
single load data frame and I guess it
goes up to gigabytes so you know that
you can buy a machine with multiple
kicks and run it as a server zone but
there is definitely an upper range where
you can't do that now the question is
whether you want to do this if you are
already interested in machine learning
do you want to run a model or a petabyte
of data would you sample if your sample
is the performance all the same it's a
sample good so all these things are
questions that data scientists and more
soil study stations are trying to to
solve right now so statisticians are
sort of scrambling to to produce
machinery that works with problems like
this where you don't have to do they
stick a reference for example to a
violation and so on but you just use all
the data so yeah there are
criticisms about well why do I want to
run a modern a petabyte of data right
but but if you wanted to you can right
so the interesting thing is that the way
things are going
been on Python it's actually pretty
pretty convenient because you're
accessing data frames the same way that
any other language will access data
frames they all translate everything to
a logical plan and then there's this
thing context in that produces an
execution model so performance is about
as good so this is a pretty old graph so
this about one year old this was hardly
discarded this was already in Python
doing these things
it was definitely slower in Python right
but after theta friends were introduced
look at this all languages are about the
same so that's one reason to say well
I'm perfectly fine with PI SPARC don't
have to move right okay so machine
learning there are a lot of steps that
you have to do normally and the cool
thing about this park is that you can do
it all in one single machine so you
don't have to do ETL on this monster
cluster then somebody gave me and then
down sample that somewhere and then run
my models and then put it back in
production in some other machine so
everything can be one single platform as
part right so everybody likes cycle
learn it's a very nice library it has a
lot of things under one single library
which is very impressive it's very easy
to use it's very easy to create new
models and follow the API that they
offer and so on it's pretty up-to-date
but it normally sticks to one machine
and that's that's problem so you can do
you can paralyze things like research on
all the course and Agua machine but
that's as far as it gets you right
although having said that you can try
this
Sparky learn package that apparently
takes cycle encode and puts it into a
spark somehow I haven't look at the guts
of how this happens so I'm not going to
talk about this okay what if you had to
do machine learning with Hadoop so
basically you are screwed because it's
so fantastically
inefficient so it touches the hard drive
for everything and that's just not a
very good idea because most machine
learning algorithms are iterative like
to think on gradient descent and so on
every time you do an iteration you touch
disk so well it totally sucks so it's
just what happened it is that as Park
Hill the MapReduce paradigm and
everybody who was running serious jobs
in my previews has moved to spark pretty
much at least the banks and so on so
well it's easier it's more efficient in
terms of hardware as well because it's
faster so things that took a week before
you can run them in a day with the same
cluster it uses more memory but what is
cheap nowadays and it keeps you a whole
bunch bunch of new things like as
streams machine learning libraries
graphs that isn't had before so it's the
total win and in terms of popularity is
going through the roof and so on but you
know that right of course there's this
resource to use MapReduce is still for
things are like single path like ETL
jobs and so on I imagine there's plenty
of Hadoop : production doing that if you
are not in hurry and you have a big
cluster there's no reason to port that
right so the interesting thing is that
the people who build SPARC and they
stood machine learners which is a huge
huge thing because hello engineers
didn't basically and this shows so they
really think about the use case where
you have to do things iteratively and
then you keep things in memory you only
speak to disk if there is no option so
it feels very convenient it feels that
somebody understood you right so you
have plenty of algorithms that are
already implemented and the ones are not
implemented are sort of coming but it's
the things is moving so them faster that
you
it's actually a problem for people who
want to contribute to it because you may
submit a patent and then wait for
somebody to integrate it and the mean
time a new version has been out and then
you're screwed
nobody can merge that No
right so it's not just one machine
learning library
it started with ml Lib it moved to a
spark ml which is now they make the
de-facto standard so it used to be that
spark ml was wrapping em and leaf
solutions and now is the other way
around the main difference between these
two is that ml live uses heart disease
which you've seen are not ideal for
Python but as part of ml uses data
frames and that's totally cool for
Python because it's as fast as any other
language system ml this time L is
something that IBM came up with
apparently is very interesting I have a
look at it much and this Keystone ml
it's another library by the
mplab the same guys that that did spark
it's kind of early days of very early
beta they apparently have very good
implementations of NLP stuff so it's
something to consider so don't think for
a second that you have to stick to a
melody so I'm still Emily is definitely
the past spark ml is where things are
going and these things are probably
worth a look maybe the thing that you
really need to do is very well implement
it here and then UPS code that
indirectly right so there are all these
things that if you're familiar with
cycle learn are totally familiar to you
as well right
pipelines cross validators I mean it's
called different but you have these
things right the interesting thing is
that they have a very elegant design so
a model and a pipeline aren't the same
thing
it's not like in cycle there that the
pipeline is one thing and a model is one
thing so they have the advantage of
looking at the architecture of things
that have been in the market for longer
and longer
they just improve for that and my get my
guess is that the scholar guys are super
deep
to computer science geeky stuff and they
do everything the most efficient way and
the most complicated way to so it's a
damn complex language so if you think
that you can pick it up on your commute
which I thought I want to be mistaken
product so it's a very big language it
has many features it has everything
worth mentioning in the history of
computer science ended up there somehow
right so then what are the advantages of
doing everything in this park assuming
that you want to do it in this park for
for once you get hyper parameter tuning
on a cluster so in mind that you've been
doing pretty serious exploration of
parameters and you had one single super
powerful machine but you know it took a
few days to test all the combinations of
parameters what if you could just plug
that same model and run it under a day
that will be very pleasant so you can
iterate more you can test more things
you get that for free so you go to
Amazon you say ok give me this number of
machines it's not that expensive I think
I have a plaster running right now that
cost me something like 10 euro per day
and it's pretty serious cluster there is
no real reason to to node to not do it
and the actual actually is greater
cluster but ok so this you may have
heard before the science is 80% dealing
with the tech linen and the 10 2 percent
remaining is about pitching so if you
have to go and do serious ETL then why
not do it in parallel if it comes for
free so you may be waiting for the data
to be cleaned this is pretty common in
Hadoop clusters and so on well just make
it faster by moving to to spark and last
but not least important models that you
can run can be a lot bigger so if you
want a model that has a billion features
why not I think one one aspect that
people I don't think people have
connected this the big data guys are not
so weak in to machine learning and the
machine learning guys are not so weak
into big data
when you have really complicated models
you barely have enough data to forget to
get along with this type of model but
the guys who do super monster datasets
they don't run complex models they
actually run kind of shitty models that
can be paralyzed easily so why so why
would you not run most of deep learning
model with thousands of free parameters
if you have the data so this is the
interesting part about doing things in
parallel when it's actually not that
much overhead just you can try more
complex models right so hard this
problem to scale up into the science add
people right so what I've seen is that
things in this world are normally very
elegant and bringing people as to have
to spit and adding contributions is kind
of easy although this is a problem
people don't publish components they go
for kind of monolithic things or nothing
and this is not ideal so one example was
a pull request implementing nonlinear
SPMS
that never got merged and now it's been
like one year and now nobody can merge
it easily so that's a pity because you
only have linear SVM's in this part
which kind of suck and somebody actually
worried and try to implement I think was
her bf and they are they're sitting
collecting dust right so you may have
heard about datasets which are a new
data type that has the same API as data
frames but it has types and this is kind
of a big deal for for scale people
because they really like their types so
I was in the room when they announced
data frames that were untyped and it was
like half the room Python guys - yay the
other half of the room is color guys
don't like not type save so now they
have a an object that has type so it's
type safe and it has the nice features
of data frame but this this monster
thing can actually do err arises at
compile time which is pretty cool
right so I'm going to dress you in the
last stretch through three projects that
I run both in Python and in Scala spark
and tell you what I found so one of them
was this goggle what you had to predict
whether some researchers are going to
get a grant this is an example of a
horrible data set there is a series
dirty lots of missing data all kind of
data transformation so you test kind of
the feature engineering part of the of
the library another one this actually in
progress is this visual cue a
competition that is going on right now
where you are given a picture and a
question and you have to answer the
question and surprisingly the features
that do most of the work are mostly
repeat so this must be a repeat ask so
you have the vectors for other features
in the image but most of the work is
known by this so then the last project
was some kind of recommender to tell you
who to follow on Twitter so if you want
some influencer to know that you're
alive basically something what like what
buffer does but better basically using a
personalized page rank to find the
influencers and then computing shortest
path and then optimizing that path so
this guy actually sees you
buffer only looks at the times that
people are away posting and that stills
in there it optimizes so this is a graph
problem mostly very iterative
personalized PageRank and so on so I'm
going to tell you my experience building
these things in Python are and Scala
spark so cattle car features we are very
used to factors but there are a little
bit of a pain in Scala you have to do
this kind of handling manually of 1000
columns and so on and when you pass
things to a model they have to be in in
a format that is very and friendly this
you have to call this vector assembler
and it gives you features as a vector
vector of features not a
pandas object or anything human friendly
it's just a vector of features
right the pipeline's story though is
super good
so if you know by playing second learn
you know pipelines in a spark they have
the same features the way they pass
parameters are different a little bit
different there are a bit more object
oriented so in cycle learn pipelines you
do it with naming conventions like name
of the model and the score is the score
name of the variable here they have this
abstraction of course but it works very
much the same and you can write custom
stages so okay the story with NLP also
pretty good they have all these
strengths transformers and these are the
equivalent things on second learn so
maybe a more proper comparison will be
spacing it has more grippy stuff on this
side on the spark side they have even
implementations of things like beddings
like were to work and so on so totally
fine now graph is tough graphics to
start with which is the the graph
library inside the spark is not doing
great with Python they don't have a
python api there is data structure
called graph frames and that one
actually does have bindings for python
but I tried and it kind of sucked so I
don't recommend it well that's that's my
note I have to finish so things I would
then like well first things that we
liked the architecture is very modular
very nice types all over the place
model fitting returns our transformer
which is nice the story about passing
parameters is very emoji news and you
can do ETL I'm a model fitting on the
same platform right the grid search
works really well on multiple machines
so you are like oh this is finished
already
how come so you are surprised by the how
fast it is this appointments feature
indexing it's the pain this assembly
thing maximum death of trees is 30 for
whatever reason you don't have matter or
lip or anything nice to plot really
people use d3
that's awesome missus like nonlinear
spms and deep learning is not their
native but there is this library called
didn't Forge a that blacks in on top of
on the Talco system right cool things
are coming that you may be interested in
everything is moving with back to the
point zero to two data frames which is
very good for Python persistence because
you can save and load pipelines and this
this is I love this idea so they're
unifying the API is for streams and
static data sets with something they
call an infinite data set so we are used
to something that is rectangular matrix
or whatever that is limited right what
if it was not limited what if it was the
bottom will be always growing
that's a stream for you right it's three
Macias an infinite dataset you don't
know where it ends so they have an API
that works on both and this coming is
packed up in serum which is pretty cool
right so what have scholars part given
as well other than distributed datasets
attributed machine learning have been
easier and cheaper to run than Hadoop
doing streams and being easier to deploy
well what have they given us so right so
okay I said the superpower for this talk
should be you can say yes or maybe to
somebody approaching do today to do a
project with Scala in a spark right tie
is pretty ambitious so the way I want to
help you say yes is to give you access
to a bunch of videos that we made for
typesafe no not type safe light band
nowadays you have to pay beers if you
say type safe we throw them anyway so
there are 25 videos where do like this
is the sign for advanced or intermediate
person who knows machine learning
already if you just want to know the how
of how to implement things everything
like feature engineering dealing with
missing data and so on on a spark in
Scala just go to this URL and all the
videos are there so that's it thank you
very much for your attention
yep yeah yeah right
so I'm going to repeat the question for
everybody so one reason why there are no
nonlinear currents in a spark is kind of
the obvious thing that is just very hard
to to do nonlinear cameras on that
cluster basically so it may be that it
never going to happen so people are
doing page to this or this and writing
papers and eventually somebody may come
up with an approximation so I think is
hopeless but okay so you say you can
just do the approximation yourself right
so you don't need anybody to do it for
you right right right yeah it's true